the live-action film Dora and the lost
city of gold looks oddly familiar there
are elements in the movie that remind us
of some major blockbuster films of the
past we're going to dissect what we know
so far about the Dora movie and point
out where you might have seen some of
these concepts before watch until the
end for the biggest copycat moment ever
the premise Dora has grown up since her
Nick jr. cartoon days now she's in high
school navigating the tricky terrain of
the teenage world according to the
synopsis of the film even though Dora
has spent most of her life exploring the
unpredictable jungle nothing could
prepare her for her most dangerous
adventure yet high school the trailer
shows Dora bidding farewell to her
parents as they go on the biggest
treasure hunt ever
Dora stays behind to face the scary high
school halls the door won't get far from
her Explorer origins she and her cousin
Diego her monkey pal boots and a ragtag
group of teens soon find themselves on a
jungle expedition to save Dora's parents
and find the lost city of gold
it's a story about a group of teens on a
wild adventure through the jungle who
must solve a mystery and save the day
this film is packed with action suspense
unlikely friendships and hilarious
moments watching the trailer will
definitely give you a sense of deja vu
it looks like they took the animated
bilingual character from the TV show and
turned her into a copy of characters
we've all seen before there are some
major similarities between this
live-action film and other popular
action mystery adventure films it seems
like they took elements of other
successful eventer films and plugged
them into the new door movie let's
breakdown in which movies they copied
and compare tomb raider imitator one of
the more obvious comparisons is the film
tomb raider in fact some are saying that
door and the lost city of gold is like
the teenage version of Lara Croft in
Tomb Raider this an OPS as'f Tomb Raider
describes Lara Croft as a fiercely
independent daughter of an eccentric
adventurer who disappeared years earlier
flora goes on a quest to solve the
mystery of her father's disappearance
she travels to his last known
destination which is a legendary tomb on
the mythical faraway land
Lara must rely on her
stubbornness and blind faith to solve
her father's disappearance that sounds
pretty similar to the plot of door and
velocity of gold
let's do a side-by-side comparison both
films have young independent daughters
check both are trying to rescue their
parents check both go on a dangerous
journey to a distant land check and both
Dora and Lara are quick-witted
adventurous stubborn and independent
check check and double check there are
also some major differences between
these two films for starters Lara Croft
is not a kids movie
it's full of terrifying encounters with
machine gun toting bad guys and a whole
lot of violence Tomb Raider is also
devoid of the comedic moments that are
littered throughout the Dora movie Dora
is a lot more adorable than the tough
and gritty Lara Croft and Laura doesn't
have a group of high school friends to
tag along with her also Lara's
definitely not a teenager but you can't
deny the similar themes that can easily
be spotted out in both films Dora's
treasure hunt
why does almost every jungle adventure
film follow a big rescue and quest for
hidden treasure surely there are other
reasons to journey through the jungle
but the Dora live-action movie isn't the
first to follow this template
Forbes magazine compared Dora and the
lost city of gold to a kids version of
national treasure in the latter movie a
historian and codebreaker who goes by
the name of Ben has spent his life
searching for a hidden ancient treasure
he goes on an expedition with a fellow
treasure hunter and they make their way
to the Arctic Circle they follow a
series of clues to locate this elusive
treasure until they find what they've
been looking for they wonder through
hallways of a tomb with torches fall
down a shaft and uncover secret maps
it's fast paced and full of suspense
Nora is also wandering through some sort
of ancient tomb she's got a backpack
full of essential tools needed for any
expedition and she's driven by the
legend her parents shared with her about
a lost treasure we can see the
similarities but it's only fair to point
out that the role of Dora is played by a
young latina actress Isabella moaner the
main character in national treasure is
played by Nicolas Cage it goes without
saying that these two are completely
opposite national treasure is not
intended for young audiences the way the
Dore movie is and aura is instilling the
Declaration of Independence
both our adventure movies where the hero
goes on a quest to discover a hidden
treasure home school to jungle freak
when we first see Dora in the trailer
she is running full-speed trying to jump
across a large rocky pit her dad tells
her doors jump comes up short and she
falls to the ground below then we
followed Dora to high school where she
must adapt to the classroom after
spending most of her childhood in the
jungle with her parents it's clear that
she does not fit in with the rest of the
students now where have we seen this
before oh right Mean Girls
in this classic teen movie Cady heron
plays a girl who just moved to the
civilized world after spending most of
her childhood in the jungle with her
parents like Dora Katy struggles to fit
in with the other kids
she is given the nickname homeschooled
jungle freak and has a hard time making
friends at first she talks about how
typical teenage disputes would be
handled in the jungle these little
fantasy sequences show kids climbing and
crawling over the lunch tables that
Katie must let go of her jungle ways if
she wants to make it in girl world Dora
is a similarily clueless new student who
must figure out how to socialize in her
new environment both Katie and Dora have
a run-in with a big yellow school bus
and they both understand that on
Wednesdays we wear pink
Dora for sure has some Cady heron vibes
in her film mystery solving teenagers
when you think of mystery solving teens
who started out as cartoon characters
you can't forget the og crew from the
iconic TV show
scooby Doo kids followed Fred Velma
Daphne Shaggy and Scooby every Saturday
morning as they rolled around in their
Mystery Machine and follow clues to find
out who was behind the haunting of an
amusement park spoiler it was always a
wealthy character who says the same line
like Dora and her friends the Scooby
squad always found themselves to be
smarter than the adults who were trying
to trick them and both crews have an
animal sidekick
there's Dora's friend boots and of
course the lovable but easily scared dog
scooby-doo just like Dora a live-action
version of the classic scooby-doo
cartoon was made
Scooby and boots are both CGI animals
who interacts with their human
counterparts and like Dora the Scooby
crew must travel to an island jungle to
solve a mystery they are
teamed up with an easily panicked friend
in the scooby film the skittish
character is Scooby's best friend shaggy
in Dora's movie it's their clumsy guide
who helps find her parents
both films have their share of funny
moments Dora's movie mirrors the bright
colors goofy moments and wacky ventures
of Scooby Doo
and they're even wearing the same outfit
as they did all those years ago in the
cartoons you think that door would have
updated her wardrobe by the time she got
to high school Jumanji
let's see if you can tell which movie we
are talking about Dora or Jumanji from
the synopsis a group of high school kids
are drawn to an adventure in the jungle
they must survive the harsh realities of
the jungle and go on the most dangerous
adventure of their lives they must work
together to discover something that has
been a mystery for many years if they
don't overcome their flaws and exceed in
their quest they might be stuck in the
jungle forever tricky right that's
actually the synopsis for Jumanji but it
sounds a lot like door and the lost city
of gold doesn't it the truth is Dora
probably borrowed a bit from Jumanji
which borrowed from the original Jumanji
film from the 90s which borrowed from
every other child to this venture story
before that there are some obvious
differences between the two films the
kids in Jumanji get trapped in the
jungle as their avatars after hitting
start on a video game in the original
film it was a board game Dora and her
friends are also taken to the jungle
against their will
but not through a video game they're
kidnapped by some bad guys and sent
there in a crate the kids in Jumanji
become different characters with
different bodies while Dora and her
friends remain themselves the whole time
we're starting to wonder if all
adventure movies follow the same concept
and storyline curious boots who is the
first character that comes to mind when
you think of a monkey who comes from the
jungle and his best friends with a human
if you said Curious George you're not
alone when we saw bootless boots in the
door trailer we couldn't help but think
of the little sweet monkey who gets into
mischief and loves the man with the
yellow hat boots is a little sweet
monkey who loves the girl with the pink
t-shirt and a purple backpack let's face
it
seeing boots with his toes all hanging
out and grabbing onto tree branches has
many fans shook however it's not the
first time fans have put boots the
monkey and Curious George together
there's hee
in a reddit thread that asks who would
win boots Sir George but given that the
voice of boots will be played by Danny
Trejo it's safe to say that boots would
be the clear Victor and any monkey
showdown with George and Dora would
definitely take down the man with the
yellow hat even if she had one hand tied
behind her back
when boots was an animated cartoon he
had a similarly high-pitched voice the
same as George but George doesn't really
talk thankfully he has a narrator that
helps express his wants and needs it's a
hard right turn to imagine the voice of
boots being played by a gruff deep
gritty voice dude who is known for his
role in the film machete then again door
is wielding a knife now so anything is
possible
Indiana Dora and now here comes the
biggest copycat moment ever mini fans
and movie critics are calling the
live-action Dora movie a teenage girl
version of Indiana Jones even the movie
posters have a similar look
it seems the makers of door in the lost
city took many pages from the Indiana
Jones playbook but they made the
intrepid explorer into a teenage girl
rather than a gruff archaeologist with a
fear of snakes doors got many things
that Indiana has she's clever always
ready with a witty comeback and she's
brave and adventurous and she doesn't
shy away from an impossible quest all
that's missing is the hat and the whip
we're not even mad at the fact that they
copied Indiana Jones the truth is the
world needs to see that girls can also
go on great adventures lead the
expedition and save the day we just hope
door doesn't wind up in a pit of snakes
door and the velocity of gold promises
to bring excitement danger hilarious
moments and acute bootless monkey with a
mean voice to a small screen whether or
not this film will live up to the
Indiana Jones hype remains to be seen
but it's always fun to follow our
favorite characters on an adventure are
there any movies the nude or flick copy
to that we missed let us know in the
comments and tell us what you think of
the new live-action boots character give
this video a big thumbs up if you think
boots is the cutest and while you're at
it don't forget to subscribe to the
things for the latest Nickelodeon news
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time
[Music]